FOX NEWS ALERT.
NANCY PELOSI IS INVITING
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO DELIVER THE
STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS IN
CONGRESS ON FEBRUARY 5.
AS YOU KNOW, THIS SPEECH WAS
INITIALLY SLATED FOR TOMORROW.
PELOSI RESCINDED HER INVITATION
DUE TO THE PARTIAL GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN WHICH HAS NOW ENDED.
WE'LL HAVE MORE ON THAT COMING
UP IN A FEW.
FIRST, THAT 2020 DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY ALREADY
TURNING INTO A CIRCUS.
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS FORMALLY
LAUNCHING HER CAMPAIGN WHERE SHE
TOOK SHOTS AT THE PRESIDENT AND
PUSHED A RADICAL AGENDA.
>> I AM RUNNING TO DECLARE ONCE
AND FOR ALL THAT HEALTH CARE IS
A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT AND WE WILL
DELIVER THAT RATE WITH MEDICARE
FOR ALL.
I AM RUNNING TO DECLARE
EDUCATION IS A FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT, AND WE WILL GUARANTEE
THAT RIGHT WITH UNIVERSAL PRE-K
AND DEBT FREE COLLEGE.
>> Jesse: AFTER CALLING FOR A
WEALTH TAX, SENATOR ELIZABETH
WARREN IS NOW PUBLICLY SHAMING
THE BILLIONAIRE OWNER OF THE
WASHINGTON REDSKINS FOR BUYING A
NEW YACHT.
ACCORDING TO A NEW REPORT,
HILLARY CLINTON IS TELLING
FRIENDS SHE HASN'T CLOSED THE
DOOR AND RUNNING AGAIN IN 2020.
BUT WAIT, THERE'S MORE.
DEMOCRATS FREAKING OUT OVER A
FORMER STARBUCKS CEO HOWARD
SCHULTZ SAYING THAT HE COULD RUN
FOR PRESIDENT AS AN INDEPENDENT.
LIBERALS FEAR A THIRD-PARTY
CANDIDATE CAN HAND FROM A SECOND
TERM.
>> I WILL RUN AS A CENTRIST
INDEPENDENT OUTSIDE OF THE
TWO-PARTY SYSTEM.
NOT ONLY THE FACT THAT THIS
PRESIDENT IS NOT QUALIFIED TO BE
THE PRESIDENT BUT THE FACT THAT
BOTH PARTIES ARE CONSISTENTLY
NOT DOING WHAT'S NECESSARY ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT TRUMP
HITTING BACK AGAINST SCHULTZ ON
TWITTER SAYING HE DOESN'T HAVE
THE GUTS TO RUN.
GREG, A LOT TO PICK THROUGH.
>> Greg: EXCITING.
IT'S LIKE 2016 ALL OVER AGAIN.
THIS IS GOING TO BE HILARIOUS.
THEY ARE RIGHT ABOUT SCHULTZ.
THAT'S THE MOST FRIGHTENING
ASPECT.
BECAUSE POLITICS HAS TO BE
BINARY, HAVE TAB REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS.
YOU PUT IN THIRD VARIABLE, HE
THROWS EVERYTHING OFF AND IT
ALLOWS ONE SIDE TO SQUEAK
THROUGH.
WE SAW THAT WITH ROSS PEROT.
YOU CAN FIX THE BALANCE IF YOU
HAVE TWO INDEPENDENTS, LIKE THE
GREEN PARTY AND THIS PARTY.
GREEN PARTY, LIBERTARIAN, RIGHT,
LEFT, THEN YOU ARE FOUR AND IT
CANCELS EACH OTHER OUT.
IT'S LIKE SPORTS.
EACH TEAM HAS THE SAME NUMBER OF
TEAMMATES.
IT DOESN'T MATTER, AS LONG AS
THEY ARE THE SAME.
CAMELOT, OKAY, THAT'S THE FIRST
TIME I'VE REALLY HEARD HER SPEAK
TIME I'VE REALLY HEARD HER SPEA.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE MUCH CHARISMA,
I DON'T THINK SO.
SHE IS LIKE AN AUTO MAKER WHO
CAN BUILD HAVE A CAR.
SHE HAS THAT PROGRESSIVE
PROMISES THAT EVERYBODY APPLAUDS
IF YOU ARE NAIVE.
BUT WHERE'S THE OTHER HALF OF
THE CAR?
HOW DO YOU GET IT GOING?
HOW DO YOU PAY FOR THIS STUFF?
MOST PROGRESSIVES, THAT'S THEIR
FLAW.
THEY CAN ONLY BUILD HALF A CAR,
AND IT'S EASY AS PART OF BUILD.
IT'S THE PROMISES.
IF YOU LOOK AT LIZ WARREN WITH
THE OUTCOME IT'S A PURELY
ADOLESCENT BELIEF.
HEY, THERE'S A RICH PERSON.
LET'S TAKE HIS STUFF AND SELL
IT.
THAT'S NOT HOW YOU DO
GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S NOT HOW YOU PAY FOR A
IT'S KIND OF SAD THAT THAT IS
HOW PRIMITIVE SHE IS.
>> Jesse: IRONIC, THE SENATOR
GOING AFTER THE OWNER OF THE
WASHINGTON REDSKINS.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK SHE WAS
AWARE OF THAT.
>> Jesse: HE SAYS THAT KAMALA
HARRIS DOESN'T HAVE A CHARISMA
TO DELIVER.
>> Jedediah: SHE HAS A LOT OF
CHARISMA COMPARED TO GILLIBRAND.
WHEN YOU WATCH THEIR PLATFORMS,
DO YOU REMEMBER WHEN OBAMACARE
WAS A RADICAL IDEA OR WHEN OBAMA
IN 2008 HAD THE JOE THE PLUMBER
MOMENTS.
OH, THE REDISTRIBUTION OF
WEALTH.
NOW THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE, YOU
HAVE BLATANT SOCIALISTS COMING
OUT.
MEDICARE FOR ALL.
>> Jesse: FREE EDUCATION.
>> Jedediah: THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
THEY WANT STUFF TO BE FREE,
WHETHER YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
EDUCATION OR HEALTH CARE BUT
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
QUALITY.
THE REASON THEY CAN'T TALK ABOUT
QUALITY IS WHAT MAKES QUALITY
BETTER IN THESE INDUSTRIES IS
THE FREE MARKET WHICH THEY
ACTIVELY OPPOSE.
I THINK IT'S REALLY INTERESTING
TO LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED ON THE
LEFT, AND ONE PRESIDENT OBAMA
WAS TALKING ABOUT THIS
FUNDAMENTAL TRANSFORMATION OF
AMERICA, SO MANY OF US WERE
SAYING IT'S GOING TO BE A
CREEPING NORMALITY LITTLE BY
LITTLE OF MORE GOVERNMENT IN
YOUR FACE AND EVERYONE WAS
SAYING NO.
HE WANTS OBAMACARE.
NO, HE DOESN'T.
HE WANTS MEDICARE FOR ALL AND
HE'S INSTITUTING OBAMACARE
BECAUSE HE KNOWS IS GOING TO
FALL AND THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE LIKE
BERNIE SANDERS ARE GOING TO RUSH
IN WITH.
THE FACT THAT THIS IS BECOME THE
MAINSTREAM OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY SHOULD HORRIFY
MODERATE DEMOCRATS.
>> Jesse: THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT IT.
JUAN, WHAT SCARES YOU MOST?
SCHULTZ GETTING IN OR
HILLARY CLINTON GETTING BACK IN?
>> Juan: I THINK INITIALS.
I THINK IF YOU DIVIDE THE
OPPOSITION POTENTIALLY IT
STRENGTHENS WHAT IS REALLY -- WE
WILL TALK ABOUT THIS IN THE NEXT
BLOCK BUT TRUMP'S POLL NUMBERS
ARE NOT GREAT EVEN BY THE BEST
MEASURES.
YOU HAVE A SHRINKING NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO IDENTIFY AS
REPUBLICAN.
WHEN YOU SAY REPUBLICANS STILL
SUPPORT TRUMP OVERWHELMINGLY,
ALTHOUGH IT'S DRIFTED A LITTLE
BIT, IT'S A SMALLER GROUP.
IF YOU TAKE AWAY A PERCENTAGE OF
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE OPPOSED TO
TRUMP TO BACK AN INDEPENDENT
LIKE SCHULTZ WHO HAS LOTS OF
MONEY, IT'S BIG TROUBLE.
THAT'S WHY I THINK YOU SEE
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG, FORMER MAYOR
OF NEW YORK, SAYING THAT HE WILL
NOT RUN AS AN INDEPENDENT.
MAYBE IT WAS GREG WHO MENTIONED
WHAT HAPPENED WITH ROSS PEROT IN
'92.
YOU CAN GO BACK TO PEOPLE LIKE
JOHN ANDERSON OR COMING FORWARD
TO PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, IT STRIKES
ME THAT YOU SEE THESE PEOPLE,
LIKE IN 2000.
PEOPLE SAID IF RALPH NADER HAD
NOT BEEN THERE, WE WOULD HAVE
HAD A DIFFERENT PRESIDENT.
IN FLORIDA.
I MUST SAY WHEN I HEAR YOU SAY
YOU DON'T THINK KAMALA HARRIS
HAS CHARISMA OR DOESN'T HAVE A
PLAN, WAIT A MINUTE.
THE DEFICIT IS EXPLODING UNDER
SOMEONE WHO HAD NO WAY OF
SAYING --
>> Greg: MEDICARE FOR ALL AND
FREE EDUCATION.
>> Juan: TRUMPS THAT I'M GOING
TO CUT TAXES, I'M GOING TO DROP
THE DEFICIT.
THE DEFICIT HAS EXPLODED THEM I
DON'T HEAR REPUBLICANS SAYING A
WORD.
>> Greg: NO MATTER WHAT YOU
DO, WHETHER YOU RAISE TAXES OR
CUT THEM, IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> Juan: IT'S CLEAR WE ARE
LOSING MONEY ON THE TAX CUT.
>> Jesse: WE AREN'T LOSING
MONEY.
THE GOVERNMENT IS LOSING MONEY.
WE HAVE MORE OF OUR MONEY.
>> Morgan: THIS HOWARD SCHULTZ
DISCUSSION IS FASCINATING TO ME.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT ROSS PEROT
GOT ALMOST 19% OF THE VOTE.
I LOOKED THIS UP TODAY.
SINCE 1788, WE'VE HAD 58
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS WITH A
THIRD-PARTY CANDIDATE WON ABOUT
5% OF THE VOTE ON AVERAGE.
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING IS
WHY WOULD YOU RUN?
YOU CAN'T WIN ANYTHING, AND THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE YOU CAN'T WIN.
I THINK WE MAY BE SHAPING UP FOR
A REALIGNING ELECTION.
YOU HAVE, IN 1912 WITH THE
PROGRESSIVE PARTY ACTUALLY GOT
MORE VOTES THAN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IN THAT ELECTION.
COULD WE HAVE A MOMENT BETWEEN
TRUMP'S POPULARITY, HOWARD
SCHULTZ RUNNING, REALIGN
AMERICAN POLITICS.
>> Greg: YOU NEED FOUR.
IF YOU HAVE THREE, IT'S GOING TO
BE A TWO TO ONE THING.
OR SIX.
IT HAS TO BE AN EVEN NUMBER.
>> Jesse: RIGHT NOW, SCHULTZ
IS A DEMOCRAT.
HE'S MUCH MORE OF A DEMOCRAT AND
REPUBLICAN.
HE SAYING THAT HE'S AN
INDEPENDENT CENTRIST.
THAT'S WHY THE DEMOCRATS ARE
FREAKING OUT.
>> Jedediah: HE IS ALSO ON A
BOOK TOUR.
HE WANTS TO SELL HIS BOOK AND HE
KNOWS THAT IF HE SAYS HE'S
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT IS GOING
TO GET A LOT OF ATTENTION.
JUAN, THE DEFICIT, YOU CAN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT THE DEFICIT IN
LESS YOU LOOK AT ENTITLEMENT
REFORM.
>> Juan: YOU CERTAINLY CAN'T
DO SOMETHING ABOUT REVENUE.
>> Jedediah: IF YOU DIDN'T CUT
THOSE TAXES, YOU WOULDN'T BOOST
THE ECONOMY.
YOU WOULD WIND UP WITH AN
ECONOMY SINKING AND YOU --
DEMOCRATS WANT TO SPEND MORE
MONEY ON MEDICARE FOR ALL WHICH
THEY CAN'T AFFORD AT ALL.
>> Juan: IN OTHER WORDS WE CAN
SPEND MONEY TO GIVE MILLIONAIRES
A TAX BREAK --
>> Jedediah: STOP SPENDING
MONEY WE DON'T HAVE AND CUT
TAXES.
>> Greg: LET'S STOP SPENDING
MONEY ON PEOPLE WHO ARE SICK.
WE HATE SICK PEOPLE.
THE FREE MARKET HAS DONE MORE
FOR THE SAKE THAN ANY
GOVERNMENT.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
PEOPLE WITHOUT HEALTH CARE.
>> Greg: LOOK IT UP.
DISEASES HAVE BEEN CURED BY THE
FREE MARKET.
>> Juan: IS WHY OBAMACARE NOW
IS POPULAR WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
ONE FINAL THOUGHT ON THIS.
ONE FINAL THOUGHT.
YOU KNOW THAT PEROT GOT 19% OF
THE VOTE.